aleppo in northern syria
parts of the city have been under siege
by assad's troops for months
few here believe the conference in
switzerland will produce a breakthrough
they're desperate for the conflict to
end
i miss my relatives who fled from here
we want to have the feeling we're living
we have a right to live because we're
people every one of us
this war is stopping us from living
i'd like to be able to go back to school
and i hope we can defeat assad
the syrian people should unite against
the tyrant
he kills children he forces people out
of their homes and he drops bombs on us
i hope we can live normally again soon
and my children can continue their
studies the west won't help us
they're just giving assad more time to
murder
send us food
we have nothing to eat here
you've forgotten that there are people
here they're starving here every day
in the capital damascus abandoned homes
and entire streets reduced to rubble
here too expectations are low for the
peace talks in switzerland
my hope for syria is that things will
get better and that people can go back
to work
the regime should go
and what do you hope for from the west
the west has never been on syria's side
why should they be now
i expect nothing from this conference
it's all just hot air